pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mercredi 1er mai la délégation de kibio
boxing club du chaudron est arrivé à la
réunion un véritable succès pour ces
jeunes du chaudron du moufia et de
plusieurs autres villes
la manne 25 médailles huit médailles
d'or cinq médailles d'argent et deux
médailles de bronze sans exception que
le club était inquiète et nous c'est ça
le coach ne l'a jamais à wharton
médailles comme ça ils reviennent de
l'hexagone où ils ont participé au
championnat de france et ont disputé des
combats dans plusieurs disciplines kick
boxing
kawan full contact et ma taille deux
jeunes âgés de 16 et 17 ans manger bio
et alexis german ont été repérés ils
sont retenus en équipe de france de kick
boxing et de kahone
mais ce n'est pas le cas de la ville
paraît qu'ils semaine marie 3e marc psa
rapport
martine aubry qu au but en demi-finale
et
ça va bientôt pour l'équipe de france
la banda la championne à moi donc ça va
pas refaire les seins
c'est faux que la pause
[Musique]
boutih
kawano directement demi finale et qui
boxing traitement fla le département de
la réunion a participé à cette belle
réussite en soutenant financièrement le
club et sa participation à ces
championnats
d'abord félicitations fait ne dit pas
assez ça c'est la réunion qui gagne il a
toujours l'impression de maman m'avait
pas fait rien il boit il fut les vrais
nasa aussi mais n'a aussi une jeunesse
que les capable d'être engagée de
d'entraîner d'aller relever des
challenges et 25 personnes du chaudron
ya une médaille c'est formidable après
aussi grand merci à mes béquilles bio
toute la famille ceux ci sont travaillés
grand merci aux parents clan tour et
donc tu vois signifiante
fiat est de voir cette belle réunion
cette belle jeunesse qu'on a confiance
elle qui gagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]